let's go to the questions from the
Internet's would it be poor taste for
John Huntsman he was our ambassador to
China just resigned to resign that post
in order to run for president against
Obama no Obama appointed him to get rid
of him politically
i shouldn t come back and be a political
force against him and we clearly need
another mormon in the race right is he a
Mormon Yeah right
well look since the Chinese own all of
our debt and are our bankers I think we
need somebody who's known them the last
couple of years and maybe knows some
strategies do they really own our debt
they own a very small portion they own
like 10% probably the same as Japan and
they you know they voluntarily by our
tea bills they have leverage if they
pull out we're in trouble I know but it
is it is way over exaggerated when
people talking about how China is
beating us and we don't worry about
China Chinese a really poor third world
you'll soon be beating us into space
China yes
why do you say that they're going to
Mars right they're going to Mars and
Mars is already red right so that's an
easy 12 months trying to no there's no
slave labor available to them if you do
leave the menus under the door joke
right now I'm just saying that this the
forces that drive exploration everything
militaristic here's a good one how would
the uprising in Egypt be different if
the people there had a right to bear
arms they you know we have too few guns
I mean too many maybe they have too few
I'll tell you who the people who have
the right to bear arms are they're
mubarak slugs and the uprising you know
different it will be very violent the
uprising has been peaceful because the
people who want to get rid of Mubarak in
tension you don't have guns but and
those guns and you know where all that
money comes from for the guns again the
US administration 1.3 billion dollars
[Applause]
first of all the Muslim is here to break
up this boys club so you need some
feminism so I'm back and I want to give
you some numbers you mentioned all those
awful statistics about Sharia and
beheadings but you did not mention that
the same report you got those numbers
from said that ninety percent of
Egyptians support freedom of religion
eighty-eight percent an impartial
judiciary eighty percent free speech
seventy-five percent opposed censorship
and the the majority of Egyptians
believe democracy is preferable to okay
wait but let me explain what that means
because it sounds like a contract yes
yeah because there's a Christian
community the cops great okay
they believe in the freedom of religion
in other words if you're already a
Christian if you've been grandfathered
in you can still be a Christian but if
you're a Muslim and you want to change
we kill you that's not cool that's one
reason why people don't tell me the last
time someone was stoned or killed for
changing their religion in Egypt Tommy I
I don't know but I'm telling you these
statistics because it just usually
it didn't it hasn't happened you got
statistics at fareed zakaria mentioned
in Time magazine and part of the reason
why it hasn't happened is because
there's a strong man in power no I'm not
suggesting I'm stay in power but my
strong man wants you to believe these
offices savages that only he can control
him he was gonna call me with my 40
billion dollars that I stole oh it's
just horrible
if you could reinstall any president in
history who would it be I know your ads
oh no who would it would it be Calvin
Coolidge that's a joke answer this is
the Hollywood Squares now your realizes
writing a biography of Calvin Coolidge
he's a noted historian then it's done a
great book on the Great Depression
called The Forgotten man silent cow he
listened he said ten problems come down
the road at you if you just wait none of
them will end up in the ditch and then
you confront the real one that's really
gonna cause problems for you
Calvin Coolidge took a nap every
afternoon so did Reagan great turned out
all right that's your basis for choosing
yeah
with presidents including George W Bush
who were very ambitious very hyper and
wanted to do an awful lot of activity
that ended up not doing so well you're
saying because they didn't have enough
because they were over ambitious Herman
could do and roll off successfully I
believe we should have the core
functions of government handled very
well one of the problems we have is
government tries to do so many things
right now it doesn't none of them well
who was it in the famous story who said
because he was known as silent cow who
said I bet my husband that I could get
you to say three words and he said you
lose he had a sense of humor too
obviously not that good apply that joke
certainly doesn't still work now that
Don't Ask Don't Tell has been repealed
should universities allow military
recruiters back on campus I guess was
that the right why they go I think I
stumped the panel but was that the
reason why they were kicked off and not
because yes there were Miller yes well
that was a no there would have been an
objection to that as well from some
groups but obviously the well it's also
you know military when you join the
military you give up a lot of the rights
and freedoms that are usually encouraged
on campuses so a lot of people think
it's in contradiction but but I think
that's awfully right opposite no I gotta
read this it was I supposed to read this
on the show okay for the past few weeks
you've had the chance to submit your own
new rules on Facebook we've seen some
great ones so far you should check them
out for yourself
go to my Facebook page to see January's
finalists and submit your own new rule
we'll pick a new finalist next month
alright thank you everybody thank you
pal
[Applause]